we're one of the hundred vessels are we
are going to Madrid from sorry Golson
and today it's a really really special
day just to say and to show the
government that we want a change podemos
give the hope to those people that they
have again the power to take their lives
control
es la cuenta tras el tiempo de la casa
para SE e probando el pueblo manipular
de el pueblo entiendo el pollo del
pasado el pueblo eso es el tick-tock la
cuenta lo primero que teníamos tendria
que cambiar es que los de la gente que
escuchar annales to da Daniel Midori
Adela Ryuga Logan behar hacer las cosas
m-pro del pueblo y no empro de de de los
lo veas me de la empresa y de la banca y
venimos nope ice road only presenta
queremos democracia
Oh